oui oui mais je suis prêt à intervenir
qu'au dit dans l'oreillette qui est en
fait une pile duracell que trump est en
danger donc aujourd'hui on est sur
mister président dans une veste de
gardes du corps ces fausses une veste de
moto ça mais sa présidente c'est un jeu
qu'on a fait il ya des années et il
vient seulement de sortir sur steam
est-ce que je perds un tube dans les
cheveux non c'est bon ce sera pas top
commentaire [ __ ] on est donc un
bodyguard comme ceux-ci hyper fidèle à
ce qu'on est dans la vie voilà cinq ans
au final watts amertume s'est fait tuer
[ __ ] c'est pas cette fois on va le
sauver les cas on est trop chaud non pas
à montreuil des zones touchées sont
celles où en est ce qu'ils veulent à
bâle où il a sauvé un petit plus cette
action héroïque s'il vous plaît c'est
parti deuxième niveau monsieur trois
sets accrochés 6 que tu vas mourir comme
ça je vois ses cheveux je l'aimé moi on
a bien besoin
la réaction manon
comme c'était beau à monsieur merci à
tous voté pour moi du coup c'est
vraiment dangereux au monde et on va
passer à travers
adacore à temps mais c'est dur
maintenant
non mais c'est un poids si le sommet que
j'aime est acquis qu'il va me licencier
direct j'ai sauvé la gelée poussé aux
mondieux magnifique magnifique c'est la
fin du chapitre
montrez moi comment sauver du président
s'il vous plaît allez kordan enfin
qu'armand surduts du 100 m haies quoi
ben voilà c'est sauver au moins me
remettre une médaille du mérite
mais je viens d'où la non mais le sketch
monga relève toi
[ __ ] de bodyguard voilà toi reculé on
va passer diack comme ça avec idéologie
tard mais plus lentement la chute non
pas à brûler ta vie tu rêves toi vite
oui je les touche et normand il tourne
normale tout comme ça qu'est ce qui va
mal et en plus je la prends moi c'était
pourtant bien trump maintenant tout le
monde sait que des spaghettis la place
des jambes mais ce terme pour ton bien
ok suivant qui se font de bombes
le président venait coiffer chaque fois
il faut y aller faut y aller non
melgueil semestre
trump vient revient voilà j'ai sauvé la
haye l'a bien pricées larcher comment
faire frère comme ça là là il est brûlé
il est sauvé la wii u talons des choix
chaud des deux mers dessus c'est que ça
ne pouvait m'aider billets dans les
bulletins il a plus assez de billets
quale bref tout reste à faire
ouah je suis clark kent j'ai dit que
j'étais clark kent
voilà comment des 100 démarches qu'on
s'appelle clark kent [ __ ] j'arrive toi
me pour là je pense que c'était comme ça
ok là il soulève on saute au dessus on
touche trop grosse et pour le balaye
bravo trump tomtom arrête arrête les
gens sont en train de voir que il 68
d'entre nous à notre liaison doit rester
secrète lâche trabalhadores live un
million de pesos si féminin c'est peu
cher pour trois sont au dessus allez on
y va dans le sable way home audio
d'avariés et là j'arrive preuve je suis
là salut ça va on est vivants bravo au
sein des sorties le public n'est pas la
db tom ils sont là bas qui sont là bas
[ __ ] mais t'es con mais non make up
attention j'obtiens nazaire il est là le
mec vraiment il se cache plus qu'il n'ya
plus de vie s'installe peur mais pas
trop non attends je pensais a compris
comment faire non c'est beaucoup le
sapeur tombe et il vise à côté attendu
le cas il ya trop d équilibre il n'est
pas tombé était censée tomber ce putt
détendre pourquoi moi je danse au
premier plan c'est fini
ouah attaque aux jo voilà mon bébé on
est bien là manon aux villes font
surface
hop là j'ai retenu et amis regardez moi
je suis une calculette et sa robe
j'ai le pousser dans moins d'une seconde
c'est pour ton bien pour éviter un tacot
géant j'ai mal à ma cheville [ __ ] à
frites et boissons soit un bond de ses
baux le troisième le troisième 3 trump
le troisième c'est bon j'ai sauvé jeu
aucun tacos ne tuera trump m'entendais
hockey encore un papier [ __ ] les mecs
ça va être koala falloir jongler tout en
esquivant une balle et en appelant mimie
mathy qu'est ce qu'il fout là au trump
industry's attaquant park avant sur un
délire du sinn avec des gens sous payés
alors comment je fais un crochet pour
monter la route non mais c'est quoi ça
cette vidéo game jam pad
oh oui mais non mais non on va employer
les grands moyens plus de buts
c'est un bodyguard buck et jean paul ii
aller là bas et la magie jeux j'y crois
encore volé mais trump mais qu'est ce
que tu fais la trobe elle tombe dans le
feu tout seul mais l'écho
non et troque donc je le pousse pour
qu'il aille sur le truc rouge mais c'est
impossible les amis pourquoi c'est
impossible parce que là le temps qu'ils
soulèvent vous savez quoi je vous
expliquais en live à chaque fois comme
ça on va tout le temps réussir mais ça
fait une heure que j allais je vais vous
montrer pourquoi c'est impossible c'est
possible alors il outre non mais qu il
est au milieu de ses employés maintenant
allez allez allez pousser vous mais
attend avec sinon je sais ce qu faire je
pense qu'au passé l'autre côté du mur et
pas ça très bien exactement comme si la
tate hausse est beau ah c'est beau alors
au lieu d'un humble mais qui tire direct
il laisse même pas le temps de calcul
est aussi beau oh c'est bon alors ça et
ce n'est un jour va choper le mec qui
tirons comment ça se passe on laisse
tirer dix mille balles
oh c'est commencer sur la longueur l'a
dévié in extremis l'attirail la rate et
600 fois du coup il commence à être un
peu plus fort au le bras de mer mais dis
pas qu'il faut non mais non
non au g us brown à bâle le coup je
pense que même ses gardes du corps ont
tout intérêt à faire ni diawara y aura
pas se mentir à les naxn qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire encore [ __ ] mais les
caps et j'ai franchement je vais devenir
salut faire quoi la fois les vite c'est
ça on va le faire
on sauvera la mairie
oh ce sauvetage in des plus grands
traits monsieur qui me permette mobilise
des humains pour voter pour toi pas des
statuts c'est leur vote sera pas pris en
compte les amis je suis fier de vous
annoncer nous avons notre diplôme de
gardes du corps ont fait la superbe
photo clichés comme aux us